drink double header two seven inning
games you want to get off to a good
start and domingo hermann pitching in
game one is probably a good idea as you
see by those numbers
really good everything except maybe the
home run seven home runs given up
in the pitcher scouting report on
domingo is don't walk this way his 4.5
walk rate is third lowest in the
american league
behind ryu and cole with a minimum of 40
innings pitched and
against his curveball that's the batting
average against 111
opponents are five for 45 against him
with just
five singles and longer outings five
starts a six plus innings we mentioned
in the pregame a reason why the yankees
have
the six most innings per start in the
majors
now here is vladimir guerrero jr
his cut out of his struck him out
swinging
so herman has a very good opening round
one two three they go all eyes turn to
the mound as alec manoa comes out in the
bronx
got about 50 family and friends that
have made their way from florida here to
watch
manoa make his major league debut here
is rugey
odor there's a change up to get him
swinging
nasty stuff as manoa strikes out odor
look at that ball dive down and away
it's who will do it
and mom's happy that's what i'm talking
about baby
[Laughter]
but now mom's got to bear down because
alec manoa's got to bear down because
here's aaron judge
and he got him look at that swing how
late judge was
might have been sitting slider and manoa
strikes out
judge she can't believe it
i mean she's trying to video it with her
phone she needs to sit down
because she's overwhelmed with emotion
and torres lifts a fly ball to center
field
grichik fighting the sun and makes the
catch
tricky play the first big league inning
for alec manoa
and his mom are in the books in the
bronx burial
at 252 four hormones fourteen rbis
tolez at first two out top of the second
no score
in game one swung on a high fly to right
down the line
frazier in the corner and he makes a
catch
i think in foul territory he crossed the
line and made the grab nice play by
clint
and in the inning no runs no hits one
left
now near his left hand hitting mike ford
to lead off against manoa
3-2 and he gets him with a back door
slider one down
so the third strikeout already for manoa
so the dew
is on with a two out single and that
will bring up brett gardner the breaking
ball grounded softly to second
a little flipped to first by simeon to
end the
inning for the yanks no runs one hit one
left
now back to the top of the order here's
marcus simeon he's a 286
12 homers and 30 rbis three infielders
on the left side
in a ball drill deep left field and the
blue jays will take the lead
on home run number 13 on the season for
marcus simeon
well marcus sivian has turned around his
season ever since the calendar switch
from april to may
he has got such a quick bat anything
inside
and he can turn on anybody's fastball
inside
and that ball was on the inner half and
he got the barrel to that baseball and
hit a rock and he popped out to the
shortstop
on the first pitch of the game and the
second time he's faced
hermione here this afternoon he has a
bullet over the fence and left
beshetti fly to center his first time
1-1
and he drills one to deep left field
and it will stay fair back-to-back home
runs
for simeon and bechet
[Applause]
when they get it rolling with the home
runs they can put up
crooked numbers in a hurry that's the
fourth time the blue jays have gone back
to back in home runs
saying hey this these guys are pretty
good i could hang around to be a
teammate of these guys i like these guys
oh two eight mirrors mike ford he struck
out his first time
3-2 and the change-up is popped up into
shallow left field
guriel is there and it makes the catch
and it's another three up three down
inning
for manoa it has been everything i think
that even his family could have hoped
for
and more so far this afternoon he walked
the first batter he's faced he has
five strikeouts he's allowed just one
base hit
and a brett gardner grounded out his
first time up and he got him swinging
for out number two
impressive but noah says hey heck with
it here it is 95 right down the middle
gardner swings through it
here is higgy with two out higashiyoka
is the chime
run half swing of the breaking ball he
went
that's a seventh strikeout for manoa
the new york yankees bring in lucas
litke veteran left-hander
this is his 17th game he's been more
than the 80s could have hoped for 21
strikeouts just three walks in
22 and a third innings and he'll face
the lefty swinging rowdy
teles and he's going to find his way to
a base center to center field
lines it into center and coming around a
third on the play is grichik
a really nice swing and there have been
so many times in teles career buck
when if he's not in a groove it seems
like he has a really good
bat against a lefty there's just
something about facing lefties
where he seems to lock in a little bit
more sometimes
so first and third two out and here is
lourdes goriel the yanks have no right
hander up in the bullpen
and he struck him out swinging brighton
ball down in it
so actually yankee pitching struck out
the side well
two-way and here is glebe yankees only
have two hits
both by and duhar one two and a slider
that torrez reaches for
weak round ball to short the throw
bounced across
but a pick by rowdy toles what a
performance today
by alec manoa just absolutely great six
innings
two hits two walks seven strikeouts
command was good
composure was great now they'll turn
things over to
jordan romano coming out of the bullpen
and romano last couple of times out i
mean he's had
wipeout stuff 99 100 mile an hour
fastball remember the three up three
down inning against the rays a few days
back striking out the side on
13 pitches looking for three big outs
here in the bottom of the seven the
first batter he'll face
will be mike ford swinging a miss on a
fast ball up and romano strikes out
ford one down in the seventh and talk
about the yankees having their problem
scoring runs they have
scored two runs or less in five of their
last eight
games the only reason they were being
able to win that
six game win streak was because they
were pitching so well fastball and a
swing and a ground ball
up the middle simeon has it bounces it
to first teles has it
a great pick by rowdy at first and
that's your ball games
romano gets the save but the big story
today of course
is alec manoa in his major league debut
with six outstanding scoreless innings